deutschlandweit sind momentan rund
13.000 lehrerinnen und lehrer nicht mal
1,5 prozent in quarantäne
nicht mal 1,5 prozent und ich glaube
dass die hygiene maßnahmen die wir
abgestimmt haben bundesweit zwischen den
ländern durchaus reifen
man muss es im blick behalten aber meine
herzliche bitte ist die einfache lösung
zu sagen erstens wir machen
wechselsystem oder wir schließen gar
schulen ist die falsche entscheidung
beides angesichts der infektionszahlen
nicht unser zentrales problem ist und
damit ist nicht gelingt corona weiter
einzudämmen was wir müssen sondern dass
eltern lehrer schüler schülerinnen und
schüler massiv verunsichert und ich
finde es auch schade sagen in aller
offenheit dass immer wenn man darüber
spricht was man als nächstes macht
lieber von den schulen gesprochen wird
und es in die schulen und auch in die
elternschaft ihn eine große unruhe
hervorruft und deshalb die zahlen sagen
deutlich wir müssen schützen wir müssen
natürlich die infektionszahlen
zurückbringen aber die schulen und die
kitas sind nicht diejenigen von denen es
ausgeht dass belag belegen die zahlen
deutschlandweit meine herzliche bitte
ist dieses nicht aus dem blick zu
verlieren
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren